All right.
This is absolutely bizarre.
Rudy Giuliani or Giuliani?
Donald Trump's personal attorney, maybe former.
I guess we don't really know at this point
what's going on.
Rudy appeared on TV on none other than Fox
News.
He was interviewed by Trump brownnoser Maria
Bartiromo.
And those are there are two different things
here that are bonkers about this video.
First is what Rudy Giuliani says, because
Rudy Giuliani now is jumping on the train
and he is going on TV and pushing chloroquine
as a treatment for coronavirus.
Rudy is not a doctor.
Trump is not a doctor.
Actual doctors are saying it's worth trying
in controlled trials, along with dozens of
other things.
But the early results seem very 50/50 about
chloroquine.
Of course, if Trump is saying it, then everybody
around Trump is saying it.
So Rudy Giuliani now recommending medications
on TV.
So we're going to play that.
But the other crazy thing about this video
is that Rudy Giuliani looks like he's had
half of a haircut in this video.
What I mean is one side of Rudy Giuliani's
head looks like he has a short haircut, like
he's almost shaved his head.
The other side doesn't.
It's very odd.
So if you're watching, look at the left side
of Rudy's head, meaning the right side of
your screen, and you'll see a ton of hair
that's all puffed up and his hair on the right
side of his head.
Your left looking at the screen is gone.
It's a very weird thing.
And contributing to Rudy Giuliani's generally
increasingly disheveled appearance.
Anyway, let's go to the substance now.
I think we should let doctors decide whether
we should use hydrochloric win, not the national
bureaucracy.
You know.
This disease can kill you.
And if hydrochloric win has side effects,
none of which are death, by the way.
Then those side effects I you may want to
endure because of the risk of death.
And it may be different if I'm twenty five
or if I'm seventy five.
Those choices should be given to doctors,
not to the bureaucrats in Washington who want
to go through three blind tests.
When we finished the three blind tests, most
of America could be gone.
And they sit there in an ivory tower, whereas
the guy sitting at Mount Sinai Hospital was
the person walking in.
Who?
Sixty five year old, 65, five old, 104 temperature.
And I sent one there just the other day.
First thing they did before they even talk
to him is give him hydroxy chloroquine.
And it's banned in New York by the governor.
Why is the governor banning it?
Everything shows that it works.
Everything shows that its side effects don't
bother you until you take it for a month or
two for chronic illness like rheumatoid arthritis
or lupus.
Five administrations have it so far, no side
effects.
Rudy says, let's let doctors decide.
That's who is deciding.
We don't need Rudy and Trump saying, try it.
And this is the new game that they're playing.
They're acting like it's bureaucrats who are
making decisions about medications.
That's not true.
The FDA has approved for emergency use really
quickly emergency use of chloroquine.
If determined appropriate by a doctor, the
side effects are never death, Rudy says.
That's wrong.
And in fact, there's something called chloroquine
poisoning.
People with heart problems can end up dying
from taking doses of chloroquine.
There are peer reviewed studies about this.
Rudy says chloroquine is banned in New York.
That's not true.
They are repeating this, but it is not true.
New York and some other states have restricted
access to chloroquine to avoid stockpiling
of the drug.
There are exemptions for clinical trials.
There are exemptions for patients hospitalized
with coronavirus.
If the doctor determines it's appropriate.
These are all lies.
And as you all know, I've been talking about
chloroquine longer than Trump.
I have been telling you this is one of dozens
of possible treatments.
We want to test it.
But Trump now being so in favor of it.
Rudy being so in favor of it.
We found out Novartis, which manufacturers
it paid Michael Cohen a million dollars for
access to Trump.
When we look at this from a political perspective,
it stinks to high heaven.
From a medical perspective, chloroquine should
be tried safely when determined by doctors
as one of many RC TS randomized clinical trials.
And we should see what comes of it.
And it just doesn't stop on Fox News with
the chloroquine